people who study insects have been all
abuzz lately following a most unlikely
discovery and the amateur entomologist
who made it a four-year-old girl with a
knack for nature found two colonies of
rare stingless bees creatures that
scientists thought were long gone and
that no adult had managed to notice
annika arnot's command of nature is
confounding to many adults thanks in
large part to biologist targe lindsey
do you know that
the carpenter bee can can eat
lavender he's her caregiver brought in
by her parents when she was three months
old so annika could explore nature in
her palo alto neighborhood they don't
look like a bumblebee which is big but
this year four-year-old annika by now a
seasoned naturalist
here
found tiny bugs that weren't just your
average insects her discovery found its
way to california's department of food
and agriculture plant pest diagnostics
branch where dr martin hauser is senior
insect biosystematist
and you're surrounded by two million
about two million dead bugs here the
bugs annika found are stingless bees
which aren't supposed to be here they
live in brazil shows you how small they
are so small they're very small and
that's a honeybee for a comparison
annika took us to the undisclosed
location under the condition we wouldn't
divulge this special tree in her special
place in this spot right here
when you came up here how many were
there
a ton
and how did stingless bees get here in
the first place
decades ago the u.s department of
agriculture was looking for bees to
boost the size of fruit and vegetable
crops
in 1950 the usda asked a brazilian
researcher to send them bee colonies to
see to have alternative pollinators wow
he sent to gainesville florida
logan utah davis and palo alto and he
said all the bees
died in one year they they didn't like
the cold weather in utah they they
couldn't compete in florida they also
went to stanford professor george
shaffer only the colonies he sent to a
doctor schaffer
survived in palo alto for eight years
but then we're like 70 years later now i
know it's for 70 years these bees are
flying around in palo alto and nobody
noticed and a four-year-old girl noticed
them this year it shows us when you when
you have a new perspective with the eyes
of a child she she just looked at that
and she says there's something different
with these bees the stingless bees
annika found were certainly descendants
of ones that had been brought in as usda
pollinators they were presumed dead and
had no representatives in dr hauser's
vast collection in fact dr houser hadn't
heard of stingless bees from brazil
until nearly 20 years ago i got a
submission from a pest control guy in
palo alto and first i thought he was
pulling a practical joke on me because
it was a stingless bee it's like if
somebody says they have a kangaroo in
their backyard the guy was richard
schmidt asked by a palo alto homeowner
to get rid of buzzing bugs in her
backyard no i didn't kill them call him
an exterminator with a heart of gold i
hadn't seen them before
captured a couple of them sent them to
our county ag department they didn't
know what they were and so they sent it
to the state i sent
these bees out nearly all over the world
to other experts and they were all
puzzling they all said where did you
find it and i said palo alto and they're
kind of like
and so
finally um he come up that it's a
species described in the year 1900 by by
a german bee researcher after he cracked
the case the tree toppled and the bees
disappeared this is a part of the bee
nest here a single remaining piece made
it into his collection
and you see there's still some of the
honey there and
that's all he had to go on until this
year when annika's bees became social
media stars on inaturalist a website
that posted pictures tarz took i was
very impressed that she found two
colonies that's very amazing that she
found two and all the scientists
found none so we need more children
looking for bees yeah yeah and i'm i'm
really happy
when when kids go outside and explore
nature that's this is how i started for
dr houser as much as the bees are a rare
find annika is too and it was important
to meet her my name is martin
and i'm very proud of you that you
discovered this piece and with that came
the biggest bug book he could find to
anika for many more discoveries to come
actually her bees aren't in the book
even after more than a hundred years of
chance sightings the bees still don't
have a name though it's been suggested
the stingless bees from brazil be named
annika bees
her eyes finding them you have the
exterminator who didn't get rid of them
at the time that he could have and we
still need a name now for these bees i
think we prefer stingless bees to sting
stinger bees and they're very different
it's hard to tell in that but i'm
telling you they were so tiny that she
saw them and knew right away
that this would be new just new it's
present little buggers
but um